say somebody is not as noble as you are
and if they really have motivations of
power influence control
how far can they go with ai the next 5
10 15 20 30 years
well i don't know about 30 years i mean
right now we know that
um
the leading edge
of ai development is
um
mostly in the public domain in fact
the best researchers are falling over
themselves to publish as quickly as
possible their latest findings
uh putting it on pre-print archive
servers even before it can appear in in
journals
now it's it's very possible that at some
point
this will shift to a more close
development regime
um and at that point it might become
harder to know
who who is where in
in the race
to uh to develop ai
but for now we have a pretty good grasp
and
i think it would be quite hard
at present to
mount a
competitive effort
in complete secrecy because
all the best researchers are really keen
to be able to publish because it's the
way that they can show to the other
researchers how good they are right if
you're just doing something in the
bowels of some corporation and you're
not allowed to tell anybody about it uh
it kind of sucks if you're one of these
people who could get worldwide fame or
or you know renowned amongst your fellow
researchers
um and
at the moment
really great ai researchers is in such
strong demand that they can kind of have
their pick and a lot of them prefer to
work for
corporations or universities that that
allow up in publishing so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]